واحد... اثنان... ثلاثة... أربعة
إذا تكلمت روح العاشق
أشعلت النار في هذا العالم
واجتثّت هذا العالم من أصله
وجعلته هباء أو كالعدم
تنشق من ذاك السماء
فلا يبقى كون ولا مكان
يسود العالم الإضطراب والهيجان
وينقلب الحفل إلى مأتم
والشمس يصيبها النقصان
فيصبح نورها أقلّ من روح الإنسان
وعن الأغراب لا تسأل...
حيث يصاغر كل مَحرم
لا يبق داء ولا دواء
لا يبق خصم ولا من يشهد
لا يبق ناي... ولا لحن
لا يبق داء ولا دواء
لا يبق خصم ولا من يشهد
لا يبق ناي... ولا لحن
ولا قيتارة تترنّم
يُشعل الحق نارا...
تحرق كل ما سواه...
فتأتي النار على المخادع
وتأتي على بُنيان ذاك العالم...
مساء الخير؛
قال:
"كُن في الحُب كالشمس،
كن في الصداقة والأخوَّة كالنهرِ،
كُن في ستر العيوبِ كالليل،
كن في التواضعِ كالتراب،
كن في الغضب كالميّت،
وأياً كنت من الخلائق،
إما أن تبدو كما أنت،
وإما أن تكون كما تبدو...".
إنّه سلطان العارفين ودليل العاشقين،
الشاعر والصوفي الكبير جلال الدين الرّومي،
الذي تحدّث عنه الشاعر الفارسي عبد الرحمن الجامي فقال:
" جلال الدين الرومي لم يكن نبيا، ولكنه أوتي كتابا".
كتاب جلال الدين الرومي، هوّ "المثنوي"،
يسمّيه الفرس بالقرآن الفارسي،
وهو ديوان شعر ضخم،
يضم نحو خمسة وأربعين ألف بيت،
مقسَّم على ستة أجزاء،
وحمل  اسم  "المثنوي"،
نسبة إلى الوزن العروضي الخاص المستعمَل في نظمه،
ويتألف من أبيات مفردة مقسمة على شطرين مقفَّيين.
إلى جانب المثنوي،
ترك الرومي كذلك ديوان" شمس تبريزي"،
ويشتمل  على إثنين وأربعين ألف بيت من الشعر،
نَظَمَها الرومي حزنا وألما على فراق
صاحبه ومرشده الروحي شمس الدين التبريزي.
كما ترك أيضا كتابا نثريا، عنوانه" فيه ما فيه"؛
وهو كتاب يحتوى على إحدى وسبعين محاضرة
القاها الرومي على مريديه.
هذا الهرم الفكري والروحي،
هو محلّ نزاع بين ثلاثة دول وهي أفغانستان وايران وتركيا،
فالرجل أفغاني المولد،
فارسي اللسان،
تركي المقام.
لكن أثر الرومي تجاوز كل حدود الجغرافيا والتاريخ، والدين واللغة،
فهو بعد أكثر من ثمانية قرون على رحيله،
يظل اكبر الشعراء والمفكرين المسلمين شهرة في الغرب،
وخاصة في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
بعد أن ترجم الشاعر الأمريكي كولمان باركس بعض قصائده،
ونشرها في كتابيه «ضروريات الرومي» و«كتاب الحب».
كولمان باركس حرّر شعر الرومي من القفص الأكاديمي،
وجعله أقرب إلى الشعر الأمريكي الحرّ،
وأدخله إلى كل بيت أمريكي.
بين سنتي 2004 و 2006،
تصدرت دواوين الرومي المؤلفات الأعلى توزيعًا في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكة،
لاسيما ديواناه «المثنوي وشمس تبريزي»،
حتى أنها فاقت توزيع سلسلة هاري بوتر.
وغنّى من قصائده عدّة فنانين أمريكيين،
منهم فنانة البوب الشهيرة مادونا،
التي غنّت من كلماته أغنية "قوّة الوداع" The Power of Good-Bye
القارئ العربي اكتشف جلال الدين الرومي
من خلال رواية "قواعد العشق الأربعون" للروائية التركية إليف شافاك،
التي شهدت رواجا كبيرا وترجمت إلى أكثر من ثلاثين لغة،
والتي مزجت فيها إليف شافاك بأسلوب رائع
بين قصة جلال الدين الرومي مع شمس الدين التبريزي
وقصة بطلة روايتها الأمريكية إيلا مع عزيز الصوفي.
على امتداد خمس مائة صفحة،
يحملك قلم إليف شافاك على أجنحة العشق
في رحلة ممتعة بين القرنين الثالث عشر ميلادي والقرن الحادي والعشرين،
دليلك في تلك الرحلة قواعد العشق كما علّمها شمس الدين التبريزي لجلال الدين الرومي.
المستشرق الإنجليزي الشهير "رينولد نيكلسون"،
كان من أوّل المهتمّين بشعر جلال الدين الرومي،
قام بترجمة مختارات من ديوانه "شمس تبريزي" منذ عام 1898،
وقضى أكثر من ثلاثين سنة في دراسة أثره،
منها خمسٍ وعشرين سنة في ترجمة ديوانه "المثنوي"،
ثم ترك المشعل لتلميذه المستشرق الإنجليزي "آرثر جون آربري"
الذي ترجم عدة قصائد للرومي.
بعد هذين القامتين في الإستشراق الإنجليزي،
جاءت مستشرقتان كبيرتان لتهتمّا بأثر جلال الدين الرومي،
وهما؛
الفرنسية "إيفا ميروفيتش،
والألمانية "آن ماري شيمل"،
وكلتاهما عرفت الطريق إلى الرومي
من خلال الشاعر الصوفي و الفيلسوف الهندي محمد إقبال،
الذي قال متحدثا عن أثر الرومي في معراجه الروحي:
"صيّر الرومي طيني جوهرا ومن غباري شاد كونًا آخر".
تعرّفت "إيفا ميروفيتش" بعد الحرب العالمية الثانية
على المستشرق الفرنسي الشهير لوي ماسينيون،
صاحب كتاب آلام الحلاج،
الذي شجّعها على دراسة أثر الفيلسوف والشاعر محمد إقبال،
حيث ترجمت بعض مؤلفاته وأشعاره إلي الفرنسية مثل: " رسالة الخلود"،
و”تطور الميتافيزيقا في فارس"،
وديوان" الأسرار والرموز"،
وديوان" رسالة الشرق"،
وكان محمّد إقبال مفتاحها للولوج لعالم جلال الدين الرومي،
فكان كتابها الأوّل حول الرومي سنة 1977 وحمل عنوان Roumi et le soufisme.
" الرومي والتصوف"
و ترجمت للفرنسية بالتعاون مع الكاتب الإيراني "محمّد مُقري" ديوان "شمس تبريزي"،
وترجمت كذلك كتاب جلال الدين الرومي "فيه ما فيه"،
وهو عمل نثري هام لفهم ديوان المثنوي،
كما ترجمت بالتعاون مع الكاتب الإيراني جمشيد مرتضوي كتاب،" ولد نامه"،
لإبن جلال الدين الرومي، "سلطان ولد"،
وهو الكتاب الذي يؤرخ لمسيرة الرومي والطريقة المولوية.
وفي نهاية حياتها كرّست عشر سنوات من الجهد،
لترجمة ديوان المثنوي كاملا،
ونشرته سنة 1990.
"إيفا ميروفيتش" بعد رحلة روحية طويلة اعتنقت الإسلام،
وفي آخر محاضرة ألقتها بمدينة قونية التركية في السادس والعشرين من ماي/ أيار 1998،
عبّرت عن رغبتها في أن تدفن في هذه المدينة،
كي تبقى تحت ظلال بركات مرشدها جلال الدين الرومي.
توفيت "إيفا ميروفيتش" بعد شهرين فقط في الرابع والعشرين من يوليو،
عن عمر تسع وثمانين سنة،
ودُفنت بمقبرة مدينة  Thiais بالقرب من باريس،
وبعد عشر سنوات تمكّن أصدقاؤها من تحقيق رغبتها،
ونقل جثمانها إلى قونية في السابع عشر من ديسمبر/كانون الأول سنة 2008،
في احتفالية يوم العُرس، ذكرى رحيل جلال الدين الرومي،
لتدفن بمقبرة  "أوشلر" المتواجدة أمام ضريح جلال الدين الرومي.
كما كان الفضل للوي ماسينيون في تعريف القارئ الفرنسي بالحسين بن منصور الحلاج،
يعود كذلك الفضل "لإيفا ميروفيتش" في نشر فكر جلال الدين الرومي في فرنسا.
إستمعوا إلى إيفا ميروفيتش تتحدّث عن جلال الدين الرومي.
في هذا السؤال الأخير وبقي لنا قليل من الوقت للحديث،
سوف نتحدث عن هذه الكونية للرومي،
لماذا يمس الرومي كل الناس في هذا العالم ويؤثر فيهم مباشرة سواء كانوا مسلمين أم لا؟
أظن أولا أنه يمثل التصوّف،
فهو من من أكبر أقطاب ومفكري التصوّف،
الذي يمثّل، وهو ما ننساه دائما، جوهر الإسلام،
وعملية إستيعاب داخلي للإسلام،
وليس أمرا هامشيا بالنسبة للإسلام.
إسلام يعاش بكل عمق داخل الروح،
تحدثنا منذ قليل عن إحتراق القلب،
وهي خاصية نجدها في كل أثر الرومي،
بعد لقائه المصيري الذي جمعه بهذا المعلّم الكبير شمس الدين من تبريز،
حيث احترق بالعشق المقدّس،
هذا يمثل احد أوجه الكونية،
وجه آخر من وجوه الكونية، أظن، أشرت منذ حين للتسبيح بحمد الله، هذا التسبيح عند الإنسان،
هذا الإنسان الذي هو على صورة الله، مثل الإنعكاس في المرآة كما يقول الرومي، هذا الإنسان الذي أصبح شاهدا على الكونية،
الرومي نفسه المثل الأعلى لهذه البيّنة على الكونية،
هل تعلم انه في القرن الثالث عشر ميلادي  في زمن لويس القديس (لويس التاسع) في فرنسا،
الرومي يتحدث عن انشطار الذرة كأنه فيزيائي من عصرنا،
يقول عندما نفتح ذرّة، سوف نجد شمس وكواكب تدور حولها،
وعلينا أن نكون حذرين لأن من هذه الذرّة قد تخرج نارا قادرة على حرق العالم،
هذا نوع من السبق العلمي الخارق للعادة حول عظمة الكون الذي هو في نفس الوقت المجرّات والذرّة،
الإنسان الذي يحتل مركز الكون،
وهو برزخ كما يقول الرومي بين النور والظلام الذي عليه أن يكون شاهدا على الكونية،
هنا يكون الرومي شاهدا بدوره عن الكونية،
هو كذلك شاهدا على الكونية لانه شاهدا على وحدة العقائد،
في رسالة الحب هذه،
لا أقول التسامح  لأنها في الغالب تبدو قيمة اختزالية ولكن بالأحرى الأخوة،
في كل ما يقول، في كل ما يعيش، في كل ما يسبح بحمد الله كما يذكر القرآن،
الطير عندما يمدّ جناحيه و الشجرة التي يسجد ظلّها لله.
الرومي مثلا أعلى للحب الإلهي،
مهما كانت العقيدة التي يدين بها،
لذلك اتباعه ومعاصريه لم يخطئوا،
فعند وفاته شيّعه الناس من مختلف الديانات إلى مثواه الأخير في قونية،
هنا كذلك أظن أنه توجد رسالة لوقتنا الحاضر،
وهي رسالة الحب التي تتجاوز كل الفوارق والاختلافات الثيولوجية دون اختزالها أو نفي خصوصيتها،
ولكن بالرجوع إلى ما هو أهم في الإنسان وفي العالم،
اي تسبيح كوني بحمد الله، تسبيح كل كائن بحمد الله،
الرومي كان المثل الأعلى  ليس فقط لأنه قطب روحي ومفكر كبير،
ولكنه أيضا احد اكبر شعراء الأدب العالمي.
المُستشرقة الثانية التي كرّست حياتها لدراسة جلال الدين الرومي هي الألمانية "آن ماري شيمل"،
التي تعلّمت العربية و الفارسية والتركية والأوردية ودرست تاريخ الفن الإسلامي في جامعة برلين،
وبعد تخرّجها درّست بجامعة هارفارد حوالي خمسا وعشرين سنة كأستاذة للثقافة الهندية الإسلامية،
من أهم مؤلفاتها "الأبعاد الصوفية في الإسلام"
و" جناح جبريل/ دراسة في الفكر الديني عند محمد إقبال"،
واهم كتاب لها كان حول جلال الدين الرومي،
وصدر سنة 1978 بالأنجليزية وحمل عنوان The Triumphal Sun,
وترجمه إلى العربية الدكتور عيسى علي العاكوب تحت عنوان "الشمس المنتصرة"،
وصدرت الترجمة عن دار التكوين بدمشق سنة 2016.
تقول آن ماري شيمل في مقدّمة كتابها "الشمس المنتصرة"،
إن ديوان "المثنوي" لجلال الدين الرومي كان أحد الأشياء القليلة التي أخرجتها معها من برلين
في شهر أفريل/نيسان سنة 1945 وهي في طريقها لمخيم الإعتقال الأمريكي بمدينة ماربورغ الألمانية،
بعد هزيمة ألمانيا النازية أمام الحلفاء،
وتضيف أن أشعار الرومي كانت بمثابة البلسم لجراحها في المعتقل.
تذكر آن ماري شيمل في كتابها أنها اهتمت بأعمال الرومي على امتداد أربعين سنة كاملة،
وتشير أن الرقم "أربعون" هو رقم ميمون في الأدب الصوفي،
فخلوة جلال الدين الرومي بمعلمه شمس الدين التبريزي،
تواصلت لمدة أربعين يوم ليكتبا قواعد العشق الأربعون.
والنبي محمد كان في الأربعين من عمره عندما نزل عليه الوحي.
والمسيح خرج إلى القفر أربعين يوما وليلة.
وطوفان نوح استمر لمدة أربعين يوما.
مبحث جلال الدين الرومي ليس سهلا،
كيف لا،
وهو يتحدّث عن نفسه في ديوانه شمس تبريزي فيقول:
"أيها المسلمون ما التدبير،
وأنا نفسي لا أعرف نفسي،
فلا أنا مسيحيٌّ،
ولا أنا يهوديٌّ،
ولا أنا مجوسيٌّ
ولا أنا مسلمٌ،
ولا أنا شرقيٌّ ولا أنا غربيٌّ،
ولا أنا بريٌّ ولا أنا بحريٌّ،
ولا أنا من عناصرِ الأرض والطبيعةِ،
ولا أنا من الأفلاك والسماوات،
ولا أنا من التُّراب ولا أنا من الماء،
ولا أنا من الهواءِ ولا أنا من النارِ،
ولا أنا من الكون ولا أنا من المكان!
ولا أنا من أهل الدنيا، ولا أنا من أهل الآخرة!
ولا أنا من أهل الجنة، ولا أنا من أهل النار!
ولا أنا من نسل آدم، ولا أنا من نسل حواء!
ولا أنا من أهل الفردوس، ولا أنا من أهل جنة الرضوان!
وإنما مكاني حيث اللّامكان،
وبرهاني حيث البرهان
فلا هو الجسد ولا هو الروح،
لأنني أنا في الحقيقة من روح روح الحبيب."
أتوقّف عند هذا الحد،
لأعود إليكم في الحلقة القادمة لأحدّثكم عن مسيرة جلال الدين الرومي،
ولقائه بشمس الدين التبريزي الذي كان بمثابة ميلاد جديد له،
وذلك من خلال أعمال المستشرقتين إيفا ميروفيتش وآن ماري شيمل.
أشكركم على المتابعة،
لا تنسوا الإشتراك في القناة وتفعيل الجرس ليصلكم كل جديد.
هذا نجيب البكوشي من باريس،
دمتم بخير وإلى لقاء قريب.